all right guys
bang bang i didn't think that you would
ever
see me and my beautiful wife oh hey
planet here
we're gonna do an episode all about the
profile dossiers that she's been writing
she's been
analyzing and studying some of the
world's most successful and interesting
people
so let's get into it maybe let's just
start with
you telling us what is the profile and
how's it been going since you left your
job
in march the profile is a media company
that i started working on
in february of 2017
it started off just as a weekly
newsletter and then it evolved
into more properties including the
profile dossier which
is an individual deep dive into
a single person who is super interesting
whether they're in business or
entertainment
sports etc um so yeah the profile
studies the world's most successful
people and companies
all right and so when you first started
doing the dossier what's kind of the
point
of a profile dossier somebody put it as
um it's kind of like a better cliff
notes
so let's say you want to learn more
about elon musk
you can go down a rabbit hole of the
internet that is
you can look up his podcasts videos he's
done
you can read articles on him you can
read books on him
all of that instead what i do is kind of
i
i compile and put together all of that
information for you
and i give you little snippets about
like hey here's elon musk on a podcast
with joe rogan
here's what it's about but then the one
thing that i do i think that's really
helpful to people is i put together a
section called techniques to try
and that's super super specific
techniques specific to that individual
person
that i've learned from them and they're
very um
they're not mushy you know what i mean
they're not like
elon musk says be original okay well how
are you more original so that's kind of
the premise
so speaking of elon musk let's just jump
into him
what exactly did you write about for him
so elon musk the way i kind of start
get the ideas for these uh dossiers is i
start with an idea first
so for me for musk the idea was okay
he's the most
original innovative and radical thinker
possibly of our time um he's a self-made
billionaire
like i want to learn more about how he
uh develops his ideas and independent
thought and i wanted to delve into
things like that
so he has the following companies that
he's founded
and or is the ceo of spacex tesla
neuralink solarcity starlink the boring
company hyperloop openai
future of life institute so basically
he's taking on
the thorniest biggest problems of
humanity
okay and so as you're doing this like
the process is you read as many
um books articles listen as many
podcasts
youtube videos etc on him and what were
the kind of takeaways that you took
after consuming
every single piece of content you could
find about elon musk so
the fascinating thing about elon musk is
that
when he looks at you when he looks at
another human he doesn't see
a human being he sees a comp he sees a
computer
in other words he looks at your brain
as a computer and he distinguishes
your hardware your mental hardware from
your mental software
so your hardware is kind of like a ball
of clay that's handed to us at birth
but it's the software that determines
the
the what kind of tool the clay gets
shaped into so that's why you have to be
very very mindful of the type of content
you're consuming on a daily basis
because if you're consuming junk food
or you know love island and the
bachelorette and shows like that
your hardware will be shaped in a
certain way whereas if you're
reading things like the profile and the
pomp letter it you will be
dangerous with knowledge so i thought
that was really interesting and
do we feel like that's why he's so smart
it's just because he read so much
information and he basically just
consumed more than everybody else
so no i think that elon is he's a very
interesting person because
he basically challenges the status quo
in ways that most people don't
he has something he calls first
principles thinking
where he keeps asking why until you can
get down to the
nitty-gritty of like what is scientific
fact behind this
why can't this be done um and
i also think that he's just very curious
so
as a kid he used to be afraid of the
dark for example
so he would ask like oh my god you know
why does it get dark why do i get scared
and then somebody he says this is a
quote but then i came to understand
dark just means the absence of photons
in the visible wavelength
400 to 700 nanometers then i thought
well it's really silly to be afraid of a
lack of photons
so like that's literally how his brain
works
i mean it's just fascinating to me that
he's so scientific and he's also
considered one of the best marketers as
well so he's able to balance that did
you find anything in there about the
balance
yeah so um there's a really really great
um
it's kind of a series of articles it's
basically a book it's it's very in-depth
it's in wait but why tim urban wrote
this thing about elon musk
and he characterized the difference
between how elon thinks
and the way most people think is being
the difference between a chef
and a cook so the reason that elon is
logical original but also creative
is because he he he's a trailblazer he
the chef
invents the recipe the cook just follows
the recipe
most people are cooks he's a chef he's
able to
through his logic through his questions
through his curiosity he's able to
concoct a recipe that's never existed
before and that's also what makes them
creative
okay so speaking of a chef grant atkins
who is
uh i think at one point the number one
chef in the world
or at least was the chef at the number
one restaurant in the world uh he
has a wild story what did you learn
about him oh okay
this is probably my favorite profile
dossier that i've ever worked on just
because i
think grant akitz is one of the most
creative people
in restaurants but also maybe in the
world
so grant akats is fascinating because
he'll go to a museum he'll look at a
piece of art on the wall
and he'll say why can't i eat off of
that
and most people don't cross their
industries like that one chef might be
inspired from another chef et cetera but
he's inspired by everything and so he
looks at a piece of art and he's like
i want to eat off of that and who says
we have to eat off of a tablecloth
who says we have to eat out of plates
and use forks and use this motion
to eat like these are things that we
just take for granted and when you're
like of course you eat from a plate what
do you what
else are you gonna eat from but he
considers his cooking and his dining
experience
a um he calls it uh it's called the
linea it's in chicago
he calls it one-third laboratory
one-third sensorium and one-third
third theater so he looks at the whole
idea
as um a story and i think the part
that's so interesting about
grant is uh if you get to know his story
he basically got
cancer on his tongue and he couldn't
taste anything which as a chef
was kind of difficult but he not only
continued being a chef but it really
forced him to focus
i think you said like not on what does
the food taste like but from memory
remembering what it tastes like
but and then that allowed him to focus
on the other aspects of eating not just
taste but experience and not just memory
also we think that the majority of taste
comes from the taste buds on our tongue
but what he discovered is that actually
they uh
the majority of your taste comes from
your sense of smell
and sense of uh vision so the way
something
looks so one of his favorite things that
he does at his restaurant
is he makes a tomato that looks like a
strawberry
so you're in your brain you're like i'm
about to eat a strawberry i'm about to
eat a strawberry and you're like oh my
god i think this tastes like a tomato
but it's it it's it's tricking you you
know what i mean it's magic
all right uh sarah blakely who is one of
the best
entrepreneurs in the world um what did
you learn about her
so sarah blakely's story is super
interesting because she's one of those
people
that she she was so naive when she
started her entrepreneurial journey
that she always saw opportunity in
failure when most people would see
failure as just
plain failure so growing up she wanted
to be a trial attorney but then she
bombed the lsat
after college she auditioned to be goofy
at disney world but she was too short
so she ended up at 27 years old moving
back to atlanta
living with her mom selling fax machines
and so
that was kind of a dead-end job and she
was like she kept telling herself like
you're better than this like you're
meant to do more than this it's all
about mindset for her
and um one night she decided to wear her
new white pants to a party
but her underwear left unflattering
panty lines so if you're a woman
you know exactly what i mean and um so
when she when she saw how good her butt
looked she was like this is an
opportunity
so she cut the feet off of her pantyhose
created spanx became the youngest
self-made billionaire and so when you
read through kind of all of her story
and her content everything what do you
take away
in terms of like those tips and
techniques
the the thing that's interesting about
sarah blakely is that when she was
growing up
her dad would make the whole family as
they sat around the table and had dinner
to go through and tell him all the kids
had to tell their dad
one thing they failed at that day and
she said that he'd be genuinely
disappointed if it wasn't like a good
meaty failure and i think that that
shaped her
brain again the software and the
hardware to think
oh something's a failure that means like
i'm trying i'm taking a risk
so that's that's why she started spanx
with no business experience um
no business background uh no investors
she didn't even tell the idea to her
family and friends
until she launched so um i think just
being naive
uh can be good and she also says that
being an
outsider to the fashion industry she she
didn't know anything about fashion but
she said
that allowed her to see things with
fresh eyes where everybody's like this
is how it's always been she was like but
why does it have to be this way
another person that you covered that's
an original thinker and
talks a lot about kind of the way they
think is malcolm gladwell
what did you learn about him so malcolm
gladwell's possibly one of the best
storytellers i've come across
um you know him for books like outliers
and the tipping point right that's one
of them
he he um talking to strangers recently
came out
he he basically says what i'm really
interested in is joy and
intellectual play the unexpected turns
that ideas can make
is to my mind one of the greatest
pleasures of being alive
so he talks a lot about idea generation
when you don't have an idea
he he recommends like go on a walk
take like make make it a point to notice
things in your neighborhood you've never
noticed go to the library he says that
when you
use google it kind of makes it it kind
of makes it like
google recommends things that it thinks
you will like or that are
the most relevant so the the most common
ideas come up first
when you go to the library you search
books things that are around but like
you can get um fresh and original ideas
one of the
my favorite things that i learned from
malcolm glad well is you know me
you know how much i care about like
things being perfect
and things being done well and right and
okay
and like me and i
i just really care and what you always
tell me is forget
perfect just get it done get it out the
door and then you can evolve the idea
right
so he says that people are actually
often drawn to things that are done
imperfectly so it's r movies books
people talk more about the flawed things
that get stuck in their heads
than the very very perfect things right
so he says
you want an aftertaste and that comes
from not everything being perfectly
blended together
the question is what is interesting and
that's what has to drive any creative
act
i love that and he's written how many
amazing books
of the way that he takes these ideas and
basically articulates them back for
people to read
uh somebody who i knew nothing about
until you covered
uh them was tara westover let's maybe
start with just the story first and then
what you learned
tara is she wrote educated
which is one of my favorite memoirs um
she was born to mormon parents in the
mountains of idaho
uh mormon survivalist parents
so that means that they didn't believe
in anything government
funded so she didn't get to go to a
hospital when she almost like
cut her hand off and she didn't get to
go to school
um so so her family life was incredibly
turbulent
she was she decided to self-educate and
take the sats
because she had an older brother who had
gone to college so she was inspired by
him
she was 17 years old when she first set
foot in a classroom and that was at
brigham young university
um i mean it's incredible and there
that's where she studied history and
learned for the first time um about
world events like the holocaust and the
civil rights movement there's a point in
the book where she raised her hand she's
like
holocaust like what do you mean by that
and all her classmates are like oh my
god
she doesn't believe the holocaust
happened she's like i genuinely don't
know what that is
and it's it's it's kind of sad it is sad
but like
what do you think about when you heard
her story i think it's just
you know there's people like that all
around the world that we just don't
consider
living in the united states or north
america with internet access and great
education and things like that
yeah uh but at the same time you know if
you kind of think back to
i knew people who had never traveled
outside of the state they grew up in or
the city they grew up in
um and so this is like that on steroids
but
i think it's more common than we
probably realize uh and for most people
who are listening to this podcast for
example
uh you know you are likely to be seeking
out new ideas or kind of new pieces of
content trying to
you know really just build an
understanding and educate yourself
uh and so it's no different um it's just
done in a different format
you know kind of from what she went
through in the story so and and one
thing that's really interesting that i
learned from her story and i always
remind myself of this
is to consider your echo chambers right
so because of her upbringing
uh she held racist homophobic and sexist
views
because of her her views were her dad's
views like she didn't know
anything else um the only way she says
she was able to change her mind
was that people let her express her
beliefs out loud
which allowed her to hear the way it
sounded
uh when they would challenge why she
thought that she would get to explain
etc
so she says they weren't really my words
they came from somewhere
else but here's here's what she says
about education that i
i really love she says education i
really believe is a privilege
we always need to be attacking the
bigotry and the prejudice
but i don't think we should be attacking
people for not having an education
that there's no way they could have
possibly had
i think that's so important one of the
people who has had
uh the most education in the world
via experiences and not a traditional
classroom is
anthony bourdain yup he anyone who's
seen his story who's watched his work
i think is a general fan uh because of
the way that he
carried his life out the sad part of the
story is obviously he
passed away um and so you went down this
deep rabbit hole and i remember when you
told me you're going to do it i was like
wow you're going to learn
so much basically tell me everything and
then you wrote this
uh piece and it's a grand slam so like
what were the
tips and tricks that you took out of
anthony bourdain and kind of
the way he lived his life at 100 miles
an hour all the time
he did and even though he he lived his
life at 100 miles an hour he always
knew and appreciated the position that
he was in he knew
that he got lucky he got chosen to be in
this position
whereas you know lots of other people
wouldn't so he he really did live
life to the fullest if you will but um
he traveled
to more than a hundred different
countries and
um one of the things that he says is you
should go rogue when you travel
so he once said that traveling to paris
to see the eiffel tower is lethal to the
soul
because you're actually it's the places
that are off the beaten path
and the ones that put you out of your
comfort zone that you know
are the ones that teach you something
right so he says
uh we tend to be over concerned with
safety and with cleanliness
in ways that stand between us so he had
a rule
whenever he went to a different country
whatever they gave him
he would eat he he didn't it doesn't
matter what there was one can i tell you
yeah okay it so they ripped a snake
uh through the middle grabbed it still
beating heart
put it in a thing and then you just
chase not chase it shoot it like a
shot he did it it's wild but he always
did that
and and he says that it's the human
awkward moments when you don't speak the
language to somebody else when there's a
little
uh miscommunication like like uh
malcolm said it's the it's the
imperfection the things that leave
an afterchase those are the memories
that you probably have yeah basically
he's like look i'm not going to travel
around the world and just go see all the
places everyone else sees i want to go
actually experience them as if i was a
local living here
and i think anyone who's traveled before
knows that is the best way to travel
um and then talk a little bit about his
thoughts around like
sharing memories with people uh over a
meal
yeah so one of the biggest lessons i
learned from him
is that he says no matter where you go
the one
tip as a traveler as a tourist you
should have
is that you shouldn't be a snob a lot of
people are they go somewhere they're
like
i don't do that oh i don't like that
this isn't environment isn't clean
enough for me he says
the dish you're eating is nowhere nearly
as important as where you are sitting
and with whom you are eating it with
that's a great piece of advice
uh somebody who did a fantastic job in
their life minus
one big situation where maybe they could
have used some better advice
uh is martha stewart now you haven't
published this one yet but we're gonna
talk about it
um just give you a little sneak peek
what did you learn about martha stewart
so long before they were social media
influencers there was martha freaking
stewart and she was more powerful
like imagine martha's well i guess you
can because there is social media today
but
when she started if there was social
media she would be everywhere so
in the year 2000 she had two magazines
27 books a weekday radio show a
syndicated ask martha newspaper column
a tv show on cbs a website a
merchandising retail partnership and a
catalog
like in and she actually is um america's
first
self-made female billionaire that's
crazy
yeah but then she became something
nobody ever thought she would be
criminal a convicted felon for insider
training a trading
a lot of people say that you know they
kind of wanted to make an example out of
her but she actually voluntarily served
that sentence before
she was uh anyway it doesn't matter so
what did you learn
i think that i think that martha
stewart's super interesting because
there's a lot of people who can reach
the top right like they can build this
empire
it takes a lot to stay on top and she's
been able to do it and redo it with
generation after generation
and she went from she took something
called women's work
which is cleaning gardening cooking and
turned it into a billion dollar empire
and the way she did that is she kept
innovating and she kept trying new
things even when it could have been
dangerous for her brand
she did a partnership with snoop dogg
like and they're best friends and that
went really well for her
she got into cbd at a time when it was
still like oh
and it turned out really well for her
her magazine martha stewart magazine was
one of the first to use a digital layout
to lay out the pages and to go digital
on the internet whereas other magazines
were like oh we're just gonna stick with
print
she is not afraid to do that and one
more thing
that i learned that i think is actually
very valuable
learn how to not give a damn she
does not care if you like her her brand
is about helping
educate you right so there's a column um
that explains how stuart's success is
completely isolated from the need
for likability and unlike some of her
like
contemporaries at the time like oprah
and things like that she was just like
you know i don't care if you like me and
i think that that's why her going to
prison
actually didn't damage her brand yeah
it's absolutely nuts i think about just
how long she's been around how relevant
how many times she's reinvented herself
and been innovative
uh speaking of she had a thirst trap on
instagram coming out of a pool
i don't know straps on the internet uh
brandon stanton is all over instagram
facebook and everywhere else he's the
guy behind humans of new york uh he's
fantastic what did you learn when
you did a deep dive on him and you also
interviewed yeah
man brandon stanton this is one of those
people that
i've been admiring his work for so long
so to get to actually speak
to him uh was really cool for me but he
cool guy
he's a cool guy he um he has spent a lot
so basically here's his quick bio
in 2010 he was uh he had graduated from
the university of georgia like me
and he was a bond trader he was working
as a bond trader in chicago
and then uh the financial crisis
happened he got
fired and he was like he took a walk a
long walk and he was like what do i
actually like to do and he realized like
i just really like taking pictures of
people like that's what i like to so he
picked up his camera
went out and started photographing
people moved to new york
um what i learned and so
by the way he he started doing that just
because he liked it not because he
thought that there would be a business
so the biggest thing i've learned from
brandon is like when you go to business
school
a lot of people say okay you're going to
start a company what's your business
plan
and i think a lot of times the best
businesses actually
don't have a clear path to profitability
or business plan
or blueprint of any sort i when i
started the profile in 2017 i never
thought it would become
a business and brandon when he started
photographing strangers on the street he
never thought he would make
money off of it and that would be his
living um so sometimes i think just
the passion overwhelms that
and it just naturally pushes you to
you're gonna make money somehow
yeah and i think also it's just like you
know that if you can have people pay
attention
right you'll always be able to monetize
that in some way whether it's ads
whether it's
um you know kind of audience supported
whether it's selling physical products
um if you're an entrepreneur and you've
got attention
then you can always monetize in some
some way uh i want to talk
about uh courtney dalwalter yep i think
it's how you pronounce her name
um absolute legend she's a savage
all right tell her story so courtney was
a tough one to do
actually because um she went on joe
rogan's podcast she's done a few
but she's just one of those people
that's very matter-of-fact
like for example if so she she's a she
she's a really long distance runner um
she won the moab
240 which is a 240.3 mile foot race
through some of utah's most challenging
terrain it took her 58
hours and she beat the second place
finisher by more than 10 hours
so she's gone through hallucination
blindness sleep deprivation
vomiting um i think if those things had
ever happened to me
my interviews would be so full of color
and exaggeration and craziness and this
thing she doesn't need to exaggerate
because she's been through this
craziness
so when like you on the joe rogan
podcast actually there's a point he's
like
he's like courtney like you're a savage
like tell me how do you
and she was like no i just run i'm fine
like she's very matter of fact
um the the thing that i like about her
is that she's
mastered she she believes that her
strength is being able to master
the art of suffering um so she's managed
to stay calm through bouts of severe
nausea
a bleeding head injury and temporary
blindness
and here's how so she calls she this is
something that she calls it
the pain cave so she's an endurance
runner so she talks about pain
as an actual place and i think that's
really interesting because
it's helpful to personify pain because
it
um kind of serves as a reminder that you
can enter it
and you can leave it but like you're in
control you're not just like i'm in pain
i can't go on
and and that's and she says she
literally says it's not a place i'm
scared to enter
it's a place i'm excited to find the
entrance to
so she's actively looking for that i
kind of like that
why i don't know i just feel like if
you've got control of it
and you know where you're going uh
there's this element of like you're
addicted to the pain so you know
do you think that because you know that
there's gonna be pain
you're kind of like eager to like your
brain isn't as shocked when it happens
of course but it's also i think that
part of
uh what the training does is they train
for the pain right
and it almost becomes meditative at some
like weird
like way right yep what is not
meditative
is arguing with your significance and uh
the last person we're going to talk
about mr john gottman
basically tries to prevent that on a
daily basis so
uh explain john gottman and uh what i
thought was voodoo science that ends up
being uh
pretty uh pretty effective so the reason
i like john gottman is because he he's
been called the einstein of love
but every time you talk about love and
marriage and relationships things tend
to be pretty mushy right like people are
just like oh you gotta be
you know do the best you can except
gottman's very scientific and
mathematical in his approach
so he um he's developed models scales
and
formulas to better predict marital
stability and divorce and couples
his research focuses on the process of
conflict within a marriage
the way couples fight and reconcile and
less
on the content of the actual argument
and i
thought that was so interesting he he
and his wife um
also a researcher they teamed up and did
this like love lab
which was essentially an apartment and
they put different couples
in this apartment over a period of time
and they filmed them
their interactions and they
uh divided them into two groups the
masters and the disasters
so they were able within like 94
accuracy predict whether a couple would
stay married or get divorced isn't that
insane what would the signal
so okay the most important signal
um there's something he calls the force
the four
horsemen of the apocalypse so these are
certain negative communication styles
that are absolutely lethal
their criticism defensiveness
stonewalling
and contempt which is the most dangerous
one look them up there they're amazing
the other thing that he believes it's
not about the grand gestures of
romance that really make a relationship
solid it's the tiny
little mundane moments so he always says
that happier couples
had a ratio of five positive
interactions
to every one negative interaction so
literally a head nod a smile like a pad
like something small counts towards that
um
and and that can enhance positivity
there's one
that i love and i really believe this is
true
it's called answering the bid so when
your partner throughout the day they
make requests
for connection and that's what he calls
a bid so
say that your partner is a bird
enthusiast which i am
and they and they point out a pretty
bird as you're on your walk
if the other person turns their head to
look at the bird
that can signify whether your
relationship is going to work or not
because over a long period of time
decades and decades
just you know giving that other person
that little bit of attention uh builds
connection over time
but like what are the odds that you're
on a walk somebody look at that birdie
the other person's like i'm not gonna
look
what are the no no no it's it's a lot
more about like the ignoring and the
neglect
like if i'm like right now hey anthony
look at this cool like meme
if you ignore me i like i feel a little
bit slighted right like and over time
that just builds
resentment and and it kind of tears
apart
the relationship that makes sense all
right we've gone over 10 of these
man i talked a lot you've done a ton of
them
what would you say is your favorite part
about doing the profile dossier
i think it for me it's i've always been
a big like observer of people
i i don't like being the center of
attention i like observing other people
and i think that this
really by listening to so many of their
conversations
and reading about them and and seeing
them do interviews
it lets you kind of be in their brain
for a little bit and see
how they think you know i agree
what have you learned because you've
read every single one of them
i think that everyone's more similar
than they are different and the world's
most successful people
uh success can be measured by happiness
you know
crazy feats like running 240 miles uh
being the richest people
you know whatever uh it's there's no
secret sauce like you just gotta do the
work
and um once you realize like literally
nobody has
a magic bullet nobody has a secret and
everyone just does the work that ends up
being successful
uh then you just realize like okay well
what work do i have to do let's go do it
and it kind of focuses you on uh
work rather than like the dream of being
successful
out of the ones that you've read um
which like lesson or thing has stayed
with you
it's probably not just one um i just
like grant atkins
uh actions packets because
like he was a chef that lost taste in
his tongue and he was like nah
i'm still gonna be the best in the world
and it made him better yeah
and oh sorry one more thing about
granite that i've found
a thread across all every single dossier
that i've
ever done the one thread is that you can
always reinvent yourself
and sometimes you shouldn't wait
so grant ackers he blows up his entire
menu every three months and starts and
makes
everyone at the at the restaurant start
over and come up with
new ideas and they're like grant this is
the best menu we've ever had and he's
like
yeah but that's that's what brings
complacency and makes you
just average like we have to keep
reinventing and keep trying new things
yeah and i think the other piece of this
too that that's really interesting
is when you think about the best way to
learn
uh to me it's studying people who are
successful
and why is that they do because it's
just actionable
things like you don't need to know you
know i mean yes you need to know two
plus two
but like there's a calculator right and
learning two plus two is necessarily
going to make you successful
but understanding the philosophy the
mindset uh and then incorporating those
things into your own
you know approach to uh solving a
problem
it's usually the things that are outside
the box so the direct application
uh ends up being you know something
about the world that other people don't
know
it's the philosophy and kind of the
persistence and
that type of stuff that ends up being
the differentiator in my opinion and for
me it's actually that we're able to
relate
more to people and their stories and
identify with them be like oh i've been
through something similar instead of
like these abstract
concepts where like i never liked
history because history was like well
world war one but if you gave me
a person in world war one in their life
journey and how it affected them
i would remember it it would stick with
me for much longer than
just world war one guns where can we
send people to find you on the internet
and uh find out about the profile
readtheprofile.com
readtheprofile.com yes do you have a
twitter account
um i do wait for the profile for myself
for yourself
i do it's at paulina underscore miranova
do you want to promote anything else oh
i'm going to give an update on my tomato
plant and how that's doing for all of
you who are curious i've been getting a
lot of those messages
okay nova on twitter
and then readtheprofile.com yes awesome
thank you for doing this thank you so
much